dans la bouche barbara bush on prend la
succession de thierry cahn alors
babouche donc moindres a elle aussi
officiellement ses fonctions demain de
femmes de du président des états unis
mais aux états unis quand on parle de la
présidence on se tourne aussi forcément
vous le savez du côté de les mouz et la
madame bush ne ressemble pas du tout à
en tirer
il est très très différentes d'un tir et
cannes avec elle c'est aussi la
réhabilitation de la famille américaine
et déjà on dit elle que c'est une femme
au grand coeur portrait de barbara bush
procès par sa capuche à l'abondante
chevelure blanche c'est ce que l'on
remarque qu'au premier abord chez
barbara bush et pourquoi pas dit elle à
63 ans avec sa taille rassurante et
quelques kilos superflus
la nouvelle première dame américaine
estime avoir passé l'âge de jouer les
mines at robes singes talons plats et
collier de fausses perles à 500 francs
barbara pierce né dans une famille aisée
de l'état de new york a toujours
privilégié la simplicité
depuis son mariage à l'âge de 19 ans et
ses tribulations d pouze d'hommes
politiques sont mariés depuis quarante
trois ans et les tâches sont bien
réparties lui au buron mois la maison
cinq enfants dix petits-enfants
c'est une véritable tribu qui va faire
éruption à la maison blanche la
vénérable résidence présidentielle
n'avait rien connu de tel depuis les
kennedy
barbara bush veut faire aménager une
salle de jeux pour tout son petit monde
cette grand-mère gâteau est aussi une
personne très engagé dans trois domaines
lutte en faveur des illettrés des sans
abri et des victimes de la leucémie
maladie qui avait emporté un de ses
enfants après huit années de vice
présidente barbara bush est évidemment
rompus à toutes les contraintes de sa
tâche mais contrairement à ronald et
nancy reagan qui restait sagement à la
maison en dehors de leurs obligations
officielles
elle veut pouvoir aller de temps à autre
dans un cinéma ou encore dîner dans un
restaurant avec son mari en faisant au
besoin un grand pied de nez au service
du protocole
et de la sécurité